I realized recently that I didn't really
understand how a prism works and I
suspect most people out there don't
[Music]
either arguably this is one of the most
widely recognized physics experiments
Ever After All how many others have
earned a place as an iconic album cover
sure some of Pink Floyd's design choices
run completely contrary to the actual
physics like why did they make the light
inside the prism white and bafflingly
why would you draw all the color as a
discreet set like a child making a
rainbow despite the fact that one of the
key points in Newton's original
experiment involving prisms was that
sunlight contains a continuous spectrum
of colors still setting that aside it is
cool that it's in pop culture at all and
any self-respecting physics Enthusiast
should know how it works but the thing I
realized is that my understanding hit a
wall pretty quickly if pressed you see
the standard explanation what you might
hear in a high school physics class for
example goes something like this when
light enters a medium like glass it
slows down in the sense that if you look
at the crests of the wave in a vacuum
those crests are traveling at C the
speed of light but inside the glass
those crests will be traveling a little
bit slower and the specific ratio
between the speed of light in a vacuum
and the speed inside a medium like this
is called the index of refraction for
that Medium the reason we use the word
refraction instead of say the index of
slowing is that if a beam of light
enters this glass at an angle then a
consequence of this slowdown is that it
bends a little bit or using the lingo it
refracts and the way my high school
physics teacher always explained this
was to imagine a tank going from some
region where it can travel relatively
quickly like concrete into something
slower like mud where if it's coming in
at an angle then as one of its Treads
hits the slow region first that tread
will be going slower while the other one
is faster causing the whole tank to
steer a little bit until that second
tread also enters the mud then it
continues straight just traveling a
little slower we'll get back to the
actual reason for bending in a bit but
at this point the high school physics
students typically learn a law known as
snail's law which specifies exactly how
much things Bend if you draw a line
perpendicular to the boundary between
the glass and water and consider the
angle between that perpendicular line
and the beam of light then Snell's law
tells us that the sign of this angle
divided by the speed of the light is
always a constant so the slower the
light the lower that angle will be and
that lets you actually calculate how
much things refract what's going on with
a prism then is that the specific amount
that light slows down depends a little
bit on its frequency for example Blue
Light which has a relatively high
frequency would get slowed down more
aggressively than red light which has a
relatively low frequency now most of the
light that you see is not a clean pure
sine wave in particular the white light
coming from the sun is not a clean sine
wave it's something much Messier but it
can be expressed as a sum of a bunch of
clean sine waves each one corresponding
to a pure spectral color so when you
shine white light into a prism like this
all those different components get
refracted by slightly different amounts
causing this iconic separation of the
pure rainbow colors so that is the
standard explanation and it's not wrong
per se it's just that all of the key
components are handed down from on high
like why would light slow down like this
and what exactly do we mean by slowing
down and even if you understand that why
would the amount that it slows down have
anything to do with the color of the
light is that just a coincidence or is
it necessary if you have a sufficiently
high standard for explanations you want
both of these facts to feel discovered
rather than feeling like they were
handed down the first explanation I saw
that started to give this feeling came
from the findan lectures on the matter
and a lot of what I'd like to do with
this video is simply animate a lot of
the key points that he makes there it
involves really digging into to think
about each individual wiggling charge in
the material and the propagating light
waves caused by each one of those
charges and how all of them superimpose
on top of each other which feels like it
should be a complete mess but it
actually works out to be not only
understandable but satisfyingly
explanatory for example it explains why
it has to depend on color and the key
intuition there really comes down to
what happens if you're bad at pushing a
child on a swing bear with me I promise
that'll make sense later also when I
mentioned on page Ron the intention to
cover this topic a lot of people had a
lot of questions about the index of
refraction for example numerous people
asked about how it's possible for this
number to be lower than one which really
does happen despite that seeming to
imply the impossibility of something
traveling faster than the speed of light
there was also a question about B
refringence which is where a material
can have two different indices of
refraction causing you to see double
when you look through it and that
actually ties in really nicely to
putting in the final puzzle piece from
the last two videos
about the barber pole phenomenon and a
couple people also asked about why light
slowing down would imply a bending like
this and I agree that deserves a better
explanation than the tank analogy I
promise we will get to all of these
questions later but it makes sense to
First lay down some groundwork by
spending the bulk of our time on the key
question of why passing through a medium
would change the speed of a light wave
at all and for this I want you to think
of your material like glass as being
broken up into a bunch of distinct
layers all perpendicular to the
direction the light is traveling and
we'll start by focusing our attention on
the effect of just one of those layers
on the light wave the true effect would
be minuscule but if you'll let me
exaggerate it for a moment what it does
is kick back the phase of the wave and
maybe it's worth a brief aside to make
sure we're all on the same page when it
comes to wave terminology if you go and
graph the function s of X when you put
some term in front of it affecting how
high that wave oscillates up and down
that's what we call the amplitude ude
when you put a term in front of X this
will affect how rapidly it oscillates if
this is meant to describe a wave over
time that term would be called the
angular frequency whereas if it's meant
to describe a wave over space that
constant would be called The Wave number
then if you were to add some other
constant inside that sign function and
notice how as you change what that
constant is it sort of slides the wave
left and right that term describes the
phase of the wave so when I say that our
light wave hitting a layer of glass es
its phase to get kicked back I mean if
you take whatever function describes it
before it hits the glass then the
function describing it after that looks
almost the same just with a little extra
something added to the input of that
sign function like I said in reality
that'll be a very small number something
proportional to the infinite tesmo
thickness of that layer but I'll keep
drawing it as something exaggerated and
keep track of the value of that phase
kick over here on the left let's say you
go and add a bunch of other layers of
the glass each one also applying their
own kick back to the phase of the wave
the question for you is what does that
new wave look like if the value of that
phase kick applied by each layer is
something really close to zero then the
wave is hardly affected at all but the
larger that phase kick the more the wave
kind of gets squished together among all
those
layers admittedly right here it looks
all kaleidoscopic and weird but that's
really just because I have a discrete
set of layers each applying an
unrealistically large kick notice what
happens if I smooth it out by doubling
the density layers but having each one
only apply half the phase kick and then
I do that again I double the density of
the layers but have each one only apply
half the phase kick as I continue this
over and over approaching a situation
where you have a Continuum of glass each
layer applying just a tiny infinitesimal
phase kick what you end up with is
identical to indistinguishable from a
wave that's simply traveling slower
oscillating up and down with the same
frequency but with a wavelength that's
been kind of scrunched up this right
here is the first key idea with the
index of refraction instead of asking
why does light slow down in glass what
we really need to ask is why does its
interaction with a single layer of that
glass cause a kickback to the phase of
the wave and then when we want to get
quantitative and understand exactly how
much the light slows down which is
critical for understanding why it
depends on color instead the real
question is how strong is that phase
kick from here it's helpful to turn back
to the fundamentals of what light even
is this is something we talked a lot
about in the last video but a little
review never hurts so let me go over the
essentials as many of you know light is
a wave in the electromagnetic field but
here we'll just be drawing the electric
field the electric field Associates each
point in 3D space with a little
three-dimensional Vector telling you
what force would be applied to a
hypothetical unit charge sitting at that
point in
Space the key thing going on with light
is that if you have a Charged particle
and something causes it to wiggle up and
down that results in these propagating
ripples in the electric field away from
the charge and that propagation is
traveling at the speed C the speed of
light whenever those ripples happen to
reach another charged particle they
cause it to wiggle up and down albeit a
little more weakly than the initial
wiggle and that in turn causes its own
propagations the way we described this
in the last video was that if at some
point in time a charge is accelerate in
then after a little delay which depends
on this speed C the existence of that
acceleration induces a force on another
charge we went over the specific Force
law describing this it's something that
can be derived Downstream of Max Bells
equations but for our purposes here the
main thing to tuck away in your mind is
that the amount of time it takes that
initial acceleration to cause any kind
of influence elsewhere travels at
exactly the speed C and really you
should think of C not so much as the
speed of light per se but as as the
speed of causality it determines how
fast any kind of influence travels it's
just that one of multiple consequences
of that is that it's the speed of light
in particular when you get a charge
oscillating up and down in a nice clean
sinusoidal motion you can think of these
Rippling effects in the electric field
as describing the force that would be
applied to another charge sitting there
as a result of that past acceleration I
will freely admit that I had a bit too
much fun in that video just simulating
how the electric field responds to
accelerating charges that I'm kind of
doing the same thing here but there are
two important facts for our pursuit of
the index of refraction the first is
that when you have multiple different
charges oscillating up and down the net
effect on the electric field is just the
sum of what it would be for each
individual charge which is kind of what
you would expect and then the way that
it shakes out is that if you have a row
of charges oscillating in sync with each
other or for our purposes today a plane
of charges all wiggling up and down in
sync Within in that plane then the
effects of each individual charge tend
to cancel each other out in most
directions except perpendicular to that
plane they actually constructively
interfere this is how you can get a
concentrated beam of light that's the
important thing if you have a layer of
charges wiggling up and down in sync
with each other then even far away from
that layer it produces this nice
sinusoidal wave in the electric field
that we're so fond of drawing to
represent
light when I draw a light wave like this
it's really only depicting the electric
field on a single one-dimensional line a
more full picture of light in three
dimensions would look something more
like this that tends to be a little bit
busier so usually we just draw the sine
wave so thinking back to the question of
why interactions with a layer of
material would cause a kickback to the
phase of the wave let's start thinking
it through when a light beam enters a
material like glass then it causes all
of the charges inside that material you
know electrons or maybe the occasional
ion to wiggle up and down in response to
that light wave you might think that
adding together all the propagations
from all those charges is a complete
nightmare but we can think about it one
layer at a
time as the light wave causes this layer
to wiggle up and down that wiggling
produces its own second order light wave
at the same frequency and it propagates
in both directions perpendicular to that
layer the overall electric field then
looks like the initial incoming light
wave added together with the second
order
Wave by far the most distracting part of
what's going on here is everything on
the left and this actually corresponds
to the light being reflected back and
from experience you all know that when
you look at water or you look at glass
light not only goes through it but some
of it gets reflected back and we could
have a whole interesting discussion on
quantifying exactly how much but in the
spirit of staying focused we will
completely ignore that for today and
only focus on what's happening to the
right of that layer you can probably
predict what I'm going to say it turns
out that when you add that second order
oscillation the overall effect is almost
identical to the incoming light but just
shift it back in Phase by a little bit
and then because many successive shifts
to the phase like this are the same
thing as light slowing down this will
ultimately explain the index of
refraction but of course the
sufficiently Curious viewers will now be
raising their hands and asking why is
that the effect when you add them
together and so here it might be worth a
little sidebar on how to think about
adding two waves together if you draw
some sine wave with some particular
amplitude some specific frequency and
some specific phase and then you draw
another sine wave also with its own
amplitude frequency and phase in general
it's very hard to think about what the
sum of those two waves should look like
as you tweak those initial
parameters in the specific case where
the frequencies are the same which is
true for our example the result will
also look like a sign sign wave with
that same frequency but even then it's a
little tricky to think about exactly how
to describe that wave it has some
amplitude and some phase and if I ask
you to concretely compute both of those
numbers based on the amplitudes and
phases of the initial waves it's not
immediately clear how you would do that
without maybe throwing a bunch of trig
identities at the problem but here's a
really nice way to think about it
imagine that first wave describes the Y
component of some rotating
Vector the length of that Vector
corresponds with the amplitude of our
wave and then the initial rotation of
that Vector corresponds with the phase
of our wave and then similarly think of
that second wave as describing the Y
component of another rotating Vector
where again the amplitude corresponds
with the length of that vector and the
phase of the wave tells us the initial
angle of that
Vector now to think about the sum of the
two waves just think about adding those
two vectors tip to tail and because they
both have the same frequency as both of
them rotate their sum kind of rotates in
lock step with
them so if you want to think about the
amplitude of a resulting wave it comes
down to the length of this Vector sum
and similarly the phase corresponds to
the angle of that Vector sum in some
cases this tells you things that you
probably already knew like if the two
phases happen to be the same then you
get constructive interference and you
have a bigger wave that results and if
the phases were 180° out of sync then
you get deconstructive interference with
a relatively small resulting wave what's
a little bit less obvious but what's
crucial for our discussion here is that
if the phase of that second wave happens
to be exactly 90° behind the phase of
the first so kind of a quarter cycle out
of sync and if that second wave is also
very small compared to the first then if
you look at the little Vector sum on the
lower left you'll notice how this means
that the resulting wave is almost
identical to the initial wave but just
shifted back in its phase by a tiny bit
moreover the size of that phase shift
depends on the specific amplitude of
that second
wave so looking back at our previous
animation where we have some wiggling
charges in a layer of glass causing
these second order propagations that
need to be added together with the
incoming light the way it works out is
that the phase of that second wave is
exactly a quarter of a cycle behind the
phase of the first so when you add them
together you get this little phase shift
and then critically the size of that
phase shift is bigger when that second
order wave is larger and then smaller
when that second order wave is smaller
again the very curious viewers will be
raising their hands and saying why does
it work out to be exactly a quarter of a
cycle behind there is a very nice reason
but it's just a little too much detail
for us today if you're curious I highly
encourage you to take a look at the
findan lectures on the matter for our
purposes step back for a second and
think about what you need to explain the
key question of prisms which is why the
index of refraction would depend on
color at all as you now know that index
depends on how much each layer of glass
kicks back the phase of the wave and
that phase kick depends on the strength
of the second order wave resulting from
charge oscillations in a layer of that
glass so you need to drill in and
understand exactly how much those
charges wiggle in response to an
incoming White Wave so let's zoom in on
that layer and think of each one of
those charged particles and even though
the specific molecular structure is
going to be something very complicated
we're going to model each one of those
charges as if it was bound to some
equilibrium position by a spring or
maybe a set of Springs I don't mean this
literally of course I just mean if we
describe the displacement of this charge
from its equilibrium with a little
Vector X that's going to depend on time
then in our model the force applied to
the charge pulling it back to that
equilibrium is going to be something
proportion to the size of that
displacement with a little
proportionality constant K this is the
same law that governs how springs work
you might ask if that's accurate and the
idea is that for very small
displacements it's actually a really
good approximation this is a very common
thing to do throughout physics we would
call it a linear restoring force and the
idea is that maybe the actual Force law
depends on the position in a much more
complicated way but we're basically
taking a low order approximation near
the
equilibrium if I just run this as a
simulation plugging in this Force law
here's what that displacement looks like
as a function of time what you get looks
like a sine wave this is called simple
harmonic motion and the frequency of
this wave is going to matter a lot for
you and me and finding that comes down
to solving a certain differential
equation because the force is really the
same thing as mass time acceleration and
the acceleration is the same thing as
the second derivative of that
displacement so what we're saying is we
want some function whose second
derivative looks like a certain constant
times that function itself self any
differential equation students among you
might enjoy thinking about how you solve
this I won't go over the full details
but the answer is reasonably intuitive
and anyone who knows a little calculus
can just check it for themselves the way
it shakes out is that if the initial
condition is that our little charge has
a velocity of zero but it's offset from
the equilibrium by a little Vector X
knot then the way it evolves over time
looks like xnot multiplied by a cosine
expression so the amplitude of this wave
is kind of uninteresting it just depends
on how far we pulled things back
originally but the meat is this
frequency term square < TK of k / M and
if you think about it this should
hopefully be at least a little intuitive
for example if you increase K which is
kind of like increasing the strength of
that spring then it results in a faster
oscillation whereas if you increase M
the mass of the particle there's a lot
more inertia and it results in a slower
oscillation this term sare otk of k / M
has a special name it's called the
resonant frequency for our simple
harmonic oscillator and being a little
more precise I should call this the
resonant angular frequency this is
always a little bit of an awkwardness
with physics where whenever you have
some kind of cyclic process when you
give an intuitive description it's
natural to phrase things in terms of the
frequency the number of cycles that this
process makes per unit time but when
doing math it's often more natural to
talk about the angular frequency which
you could think of as describing how
much angle this process covers in
radians per unit time it's just the same
as the frequency but multiply by 2 pi so
for example if you have something like a
cosine expression which you might think
of as describing the X component of a
cycling Vector like this then the term
sitting right in front of the T in that
cosine is the angular frequency this is
why angular frequency makes the math a
little cleaner for example in our simple
harmonic motion the term sitting in
front of T looks like theare otk of k /
M which I'm writing as Omega subr let's
package all of that up and call that our
solution in the simple case where
there's no external force acting on on
our charged particle but of course what
we're interested in is what happens when
you shine a beam of light on this
material which intuitively causes this
charge to jiggle but the question is how
much in our equation this looks like
adding a new Force term corresponding to
the light wave that Force oscillates up
and down also According to some kind of
cosine function but this time with a
distinct angular frequency that I'm
going to call Omega sub l e KN here
describes the strength of the wave and
then Q describes the charge of whatever
particle we're modeling as usual it's a
lot easier to think about when we only
draw a subset of that light wave and in
this case we're going to draw it on the
plane of the layer of material that we
care about you might think of gusts of
wind blowing our little ball on the
spring up and down in a clean sinusoidal
pattern or as another analogy it's
similar to pushing a child on a swing
the swing would oscillate on its own due
to the force of gravity but you as The
Pusher are applying an external Force
which itself is oscillating over time
although a key difference here is that
the frequency of that external force in
general has nothing to do with the
resonant frequency of that little
oscillator the better analogy would be
if you're pushing the child on the swing
with a cyclic force that has nothing to
do with what the swing naturally wants
to do and my favorite part in literally
trying to do this with my niece is that
at some point she gently murmurs to
herself this isn't how Mom does it now
in trying to understand how much our
charge is oscillating in response to the
incoming light let me start by just
simulating it and plotting the
result you'll notice that there's a
little startup period where it kind of
has to get going but then after that
mercifully it looks nice and clean just
like another sine wave now you might be
thinking yeah yeah everything is sine
waves but it's important to understand
that this one has a very different
character from the sine wave we saw
earlier earlier without any external
forces the frequency of that wave came
down to the spring constant and the mass
which is to say it depends exclusively
on material properties of the glass by
contrast with this external cycling
driving force the frequency in that
steady state is the same as the
frequency of the light and then in our
first case the amplitude of the wave was
kind of uninteresting it just depends on
how far you pulled the spring out to
begin with but in the second case the
amplitude of this wave is actually where
all the interesting stuff happens
exactly how much will this charge be
oscillating in response to the light
wave again I won't go over the full
details of solving this but any eager
calculus students among you might enjoy
going through the exercise where if you
just guess that a solution looks like a
cosine wave with the same frequency as
the light and you solve for the
amplitude you can get a concrete
solution to this equation that looks
like this this is worth unpacking for a
bit and just to be clear this is only
describing things in the steady state
after things have kind of gotten up and
going a fully descriptive solution would
be notably more complicated as I said
everything interesting here comes down
to the amplitude which here looks like a
large collection of constants most of
which should be pretty intuitive if you
take a moment to think about it for
example it is proportional to the
strength of that incoming light wave so
the stronger the light the more the
oscillations it's also proportional to
the charge which again makes sense and
the real heart of the matter comes down
to what's sitting in the denominator
here the difference between the square
of the resonant frequency and the square
of the light frequency and to build a
little intuition take a moment to think
about what would happen if the frequency
of the incoming light was something very
close to the resonant frequency of this
oscillator this is analogous to the
normal situation pushing a child on a
swing where the frequency of your Force
lines up quite closely with what the
swing wants to do in this case running
the simulation notice how the
oscillations of that particle will grow
and grow and grow becoming quite large
over
time some of you may know the famous
example of the Millennium bridge in
London where on its opening day it
started oscillating way more than the
engineers expected it to and what was
going on is that the frequency of the
steps of the crowd lined up very closely
with a resonant frequency causing this
worryingly High
amplitude by contrast notice what
happens in the simulation if the
frequency of the light Omega sub L is
something much smaller than the resonant
frequency for this particular simulation
it takes a little bit of a moment before
things get into their full swing
eventually it finds a nice sinusoidal
motion but the amplitude of that motion
is much more modest in comparison so
what our equation is telling us is that
the larger the difference between those
frequencies then the bigger the
denominator so the smaller the overall
wiggle to that charge and again this is
something you can see in the footage
with my niece as I'm applying a force
with a frequency that's very different
from what the swing wants to do she ends
up oscillating at the same frequency as
my Force but she's going at a relatively
low
amplitude stepping back what this means
is that as you shine light into a
material like glass it's not just that
it induces Wiggles in the charges of
that material but the specific size of
those Wiggles depends on the frequency
of the light as a consequence of this
denominator term and the more those
wiggle the bigger the size of the second
order wave caused by that layer which in
turn causes a bigger shift to the phase
of the overall wave because a lot of
different shifts to the phase are what
causes this apparent slow down to the
light it means that the amount that it
will slow down ultimately depends on the
frequency of the light so that is the
real reason why prisms work you cannot
truly explain the light separation until
you get down to the driven harmonic
oscillator now I have left out a number
of details and again I encourage the
Curious viewers to take a look at the
Fineman lectures that a lot of this is
based on one quite important detail that
would be a little criminal not to
mention is that when we're modeling our
charge as a little harmonic oscillator
with this linear restoring Force there
should really also be a term that
depends on the velocity of that charge
you might think of this as a kind of
drag Force this term accounts for the
fact that energy from the incoming light
wave is absorbed by the material without
it this whole explanation would seem to
imply that light always passes through
every material not just glass and water
when as you can tell just by looking
around there's all sorts of materials
for which light is mostly reflected and
absorbed as I mentioned at the start
folks on patreon had numerous questions
about the index of refraction like how
it can be less than one and why slowing
implies bending so I made a supplemental
video answering a handful of those
questions which should be published in
just a few days in the meantime my
friend Mitha from the channel Looking
Glass Universe just put out a pair of
videos on the related but definitely
distinct question of whether light slows
down in a medium not in the sense of
following the crests of a clean pure
sine wave in a steady state but in the
sense of trying to send information
through that Medium like with a little
wave packet I definitely owe the
existence of this video to many
conversations with her about this topic
and viewers here will definitely enjoy
taking a look especially at the second
one by the way some collaborators and I
made this notebook that I think a lot of
viewers might enjoy and given that it's
the holiday season it seems worth a
quick mention the premise is that every
one of the pages has a quote that's
related to math and I had a lot of fun
curating them all trying to constrain
myself to quotes conveying some
genuinely thought-provoking idea and
then aside from the content I basically
made the kind of notebook that I most
enjoy taking notes in something that's
readily portable with very faint grid
lines helpful for diagrams but otherwise
unobtrusive all bound in this nice soft
faux leather if that seams up your alley
you can find them in the three blue one
brown store next to a lot of other
mathematical
[Music]
merchandise